michael cohen appeared in a new york
court to do what lawyers do best defend
himself cohen was forced to reveal his
entire client list of a whopping three
people one of his clients is president
Trump for whom he arranged a hush money
payment to keep porn star stormy Daniels
quiet about their alleged affair another
client is RNC fundraiser Eliot Brody for
whom Cohen arranged another hush money
payment to keep a Playboy model quiet
after Brody allegedly got her pregnant
this is what Michael Kohn does he's the
Atticus Finch of getting women to shut
up about affairs allegedly and yesterday
the court revealed Cohen's third client
Sean Hannity who clarified his
connection with Cohen last night on a
show let me set the record straight
here's the truth I did have occasional
brief conversations with Michael Kohn my
questions exclusively almost focused on
real estate that's all there is nothing
more there you go say this isn't some
tawdry woman silencing hush deal Hannity
was just talking to Cohn about real
estate so everyone should just relax
because it's obvious what happened Sean
Hannity the house
if house and had Michael Cohen pay it to
keep quiet sure I get it
we've all spent some late night swiping
through Zillow looking for a smoke
inside piece of property
I mean who among us hasn't seen a thick
four bedroom and the burbs with a tight
garage and thought I got a vehicle I'd
like to slip in there it's just human
nature and I'm sorry Sean had to have
his private life dragged out into the
public eye but what happened to privacy
of course the perverted mainstream media
is going to speculate about added a
steamy tryst with that Long Island
colonial seen all over the pages of real
estate smut rag Better Homes and Gardens
his hands caressing the chimney lips
exploring the wainscoting taking up not
a nibble of a banister liberals get your
minds out of the gutter because the
gutter is where Hannah these balls go
will be not conservatives snubbed again
wall punch the 2018 Pulitzer Prize
winners were announced yesterday and
like all elitist awards shows the
Grammys the Oscars the Raymour and
Flanigan futon salesman of the Month
award it turned out to be just another
liberal circle-jerk jacket the 2018
Pulitzer Prizes were announced the New
York Times and Washington Post shared
the National reporting prize for their
ongoing coverage of the Russian
investigation The New York Times in The
New Yorker were both recognized
yesterday for breaking news of the
Harvey Weinstein scandal the post also
won the Investigative Reporting prize
for revealing decades-old allegations of
sexual misconduct against Senate
candidate ruined more great the post won
for a story so old Roy Moore wouldn't
even approach it in a mall
journalism awards just like fax data and
rigorous investigative research have a
clear liberal bias we're not about to
let the brilliant reporting on the right
go unrecognized
here to give their perspective on the
Pulitzers is our own citizen journalist
Josh sharp and Aaron taxers are just
another awards show where the left can
pat themselves on the back then complain
that their hand did not have consent to
touch their back and liberals approach
to journalism is completely outdated no
one reads newspapers anymore except
hostages holding him up to show it day
in it yeah and William H Macy to see if
he's a crossword puzzle and yeah well
keep dreaming William Hussein Macy tell
me who got shafted this year by the
Pulitzer okay everyone on Fox News again
take Sean Hannity he exposed Hillary
Clinton's vast criminal network and he
reexpose 'as it every single night but
he really deserves a Pulitzer for his
coverage of how DNC employs Seth rich
was murdered by Democrats a story so
brave that it was retracted and now his
network is being sued any hack can sit
at a desk call sources verify facts it
takes a real maverick to go on TV with
nothing but a vape and a neck and report
on what should be the truth yeah you
know it still is in my book in my book
is a feeling exactly what else you got
okay well there's also Tucker Carlson
for relentlessly shining a spotlight on
America's most oppressed group men and
Tucker debuted his men in America's
segment during International Women's
Month Oh brilliant move tuck maybe next
you could do a profiles in white courage
segments during Black History Month who
or how about using Cinco de Mayo to well
say anything you normally would say
about Mexican is its groundbreaking
stuff for sure but there are so many
deserving reporters on the right like
what about us I think we deserve a
Pulitzer for our reporting yeah we broke
so many stories on our vlogs and
snapchats like how Ruth Bader Ginsburg
has lived in a sewer for 22 years yeah
or how does isn't a language it's a
feminist way of splitting checks and
wait till we break our story about how
human clones are being grown inside of
live animals oh Aaron actually
Infowars scooped us on that yesterday oh
my god really yeah roll it Chuck Japan
to lift the man on growing humanoids
inside animals humans will be
genetically modified for the first time
in Europe yeah right it's all mainstream
news now but do I get patted on the back
no no no exactly he never gets padded on
the back instead he gets punched in the
dick by YouTube for slandering kids
after a school shooting yeah but luckily
we get the last laugh take
photojournalist Ryan Kelly who just won
the Pulitzer for his stirring image of
the Charlottesville rally this is true
he now runs social media for a Virginia
brewery so if you liked the way he
unforgettably captured America's racial
boiling point wait till you see the
Instagram filter he uses to make the
Hefeweizen pop meanwhile Sean Hannity
doesn't have a Pulitzer but last year he
made 36 million dollars the market has
spoken
second investigative journalist yeah and
congrats Sean enjoy your 36 mill with
that money you can buy a lot of houses
you dirty dog
[Music]